c'est incroyable vous êtes déjà plus de
200 milles à me suivre sur ma chaîne le
cap a été franchi hier en fin de journée
et c'est allé très vite il ya quelques
jours je voyais la barre des cent mille
abonnés approché et je m'apprêtais à
vous remercier
aujourd'hui vous êtes deux fois plus
nombreux que je vous adresse donc deux
fois plus de remerciement deux cent
mille merci pour vos pouces bleus et vos
messages de soutien et d'encouragement
qui chaque matin sont pour moi une
source de motivation
alors certains aimeraient des vidéos un
peu plus longue
j'ai réfléchi on verra après le
confinement pour le moment je me
concentre sur ses capsules 2d confinés
sur l'écriture des prochains numéros du
monde de jeannie vous pouvez d'ailleurs
retrouver toutes les capsules 2d confiné
en cliquant à gauche
et si vous n'êtes pas encore abonné en
cliquant à droite
encore une fois je vous remercie d'être
chaque jour un peu plus nombreux et ça
va très vite
je crois que je fais une capsule de des
confinés sur la vitesse de la lumière
allez à bientôt et n'oubliez pas nous
sommes confinés
mais en restant lien